حسنًا، الوضع في الضفة الغربية
هو الأسوأ منذ
سنوات عديدة في الواقع كان سيئًا بالفعل
قبل 7 أكتوبر أه هذا العام
كان عامًا قياسيًا من حيث أو العام الماضي
عفوًا 2023 كان عامًا قياسيًا في  من
حيث الأرواح المفقودة في نهاية
العام أه شيء مثل أكثر من 500
فلسطيني قُتل أكثر من
نصفهم أه كانوا لاجئين أه هذا
العدد أكثر من ثلاثة أضعاف عام 2022
الذي كان أسوأ عام على الإطلاق
اعتقدنا أنه يمكن'  لن أصبح أسوأ من عام
2022 ودخلنا عام 2023 لذلك كان
عامًا عنيفًا للغاية منذ 7
أكتوبر وقد اشتدت الأمور أه
لدينا توغلات متكررة أه أكثر من
10000 أه توغل عسكري إسرائيلي في
الضفة الغربية طوال عام 2023 و أ
جزء كبير منهم جاء بعد 7
أكتوبر، واو، تم القبض على 6000 شخص، لذلك
فهو سياق عنيف للغاية ومتقلب للغاية
في الوقت الحالي،
وقال فيليب لازاريني أيضًا وسأقتبس منه
مرة أخرى أن الأحداث الأخيرة تسببت في
أضرار جسيمة للبنية التحتية بما في ذلك المياه
و  شبكات الكهرباء وأثرت على
مجتمعات بأكملها الآن يقول منتقدو إسرائيل إن هناك
استهدافًا متعمدًا
للبنية التحتية في غزة، هل ترون
أنه في الضفة الغربية تدمير متعمد
لشركات الطرق أه
الممتلكات الخاصة وما إلى ذلك هناك
الكثير من مقاطع الفيديو
هناك نعم حسنًا، إنه غير متناسب
أعني أن هذه هي الطريقة التي
سأصف بها الأمر الآن إذا تحدثنا مع
نظرائنا العسكريين في إسرائيل
ولدينا اجتماعات منتظمة معهم، فإن
اهتمامهم ينصب على
العبوات الناسفة (العبوات الناسفة) المدفونة في
الشارع أو على جوانب الطرق و
تمزيق شبكات الطرق أه
بمعدات ثقيلة جدا معدات إزالة التعدين
أه ليس من نوع
الأضرار الجانبية مشكلة إتلاف
شبكات المياه شبكات الكهرباء شبكات
الاتصالات في محاولة
للتعامل مع العبوات الناسفة أم لكن بالتأكيد أه أه
المساكن المنزلية لديها  أه
تضررت بشدة أه، لقد
تضررت المحلات التجارية حتى مكاتبنا الخاصة قد
تأثرت، لذا فإن الأضرار التي لحقت بالبنية التحتية المادية
لها تأثير أم اه كما
تعلم أن لها هذا التأثير عبر
مخيم للاجئين أو عبر قرية أه
لأن البلديات يمكنها  لا أواكب
هذا المستوى من الضرر كما أخشى